day of symbolism of History
and of the future we welcome Germany's
bundes counselor Olaf Schultz
counselor
bundes counselor Hadley have been coming
in Europa Parliament
Chancellor welcome to the European
Parliament let's be safeguarded without
the making of creative efforts
proportionate
for the dangers which threaten it
so Begins the Declaration presented by
Robert Schumann on 9th May 1915.
it rings true today
every year
on this day we celebrate Europe an
unprecedented project of reconciliation
fundamentally based on solidarity
a project that brings people together
without trying to make us all the same
a project that little light that
permeated
through iron curtains and concrete walls
Europe day reminds us of what is
possible when we come together
of the responsibility that we need
to have to keep moving forward
the Schumann declaration our European
Union took bravery
change takes courage
of the European Union
is not perfect I know many share our
frustrations with some of our processes
but the fundamental pillars of Hope
of possibility of Freedom democracy and
the rule of law make this political
project unique
we cannot take what we stand for
and what we have achieved
and what we must achieve still
for granted we must keep evolving
European progress was made possible
thanks to daring Solutions
and more daring Solutions will be needed
moving forward
I know we can count on Germany for just
that
yours dear Chancellor is a member state
which shows unwavering commitment to the
betterment of Europe
so let me thank you for Germany's
support for Ukraine
for Germany's contribution to the
construction
of new EU security architecture for
Germany pushing new technologies
for Germany defending human rights such
as the rights of women and men in Iran
and for so much more
Chancellor you have said we have every
reason to be more optimistic about our
future
that is the spirit we must drive us
forward we must reform
anticipate change not suffer it
we must find that courage that
underpinned the Schumann declaration
again
we must help that light keep shining
brighter we know that we are so much
stronger when we are together and we
will look to Germany as to all the
member states to help reform and prepare
our European future the European Union
matters it is worth it is
foreign
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen members
well thank you very much for the
opportunity
to speak to you today on Europe day in
this special place your invitation
honors and touches me I'm honored
because you
are the freely elected members of the
European Parliament and you represent
450 million Europeans the citizens of
Europe and I'm touched because the 9th
of May
is the appropriate forward-looking
response to the world war Unleashed by
Germany the response to destructive
nationalism and imperialistic
megalomania
today 73 years ago the French foreign
minister Robert Schuman proposed
creating an organized and living Europe
at the start we had the pooling of colon
Steel
so those goods that for decades had been
used to manufacture weapons
weapons which are grandfathers and great
grandfathers had used to shoot at each
other
the dream of the fathers and mothers of
Europe was to end this murderous cycle
for once and for all
and this is a dream that has been
fulfilled for us
war between our peoples has become
unimaginable
and that's thanks to the European Union
and that's something that benefits us
all
but looking
in the direct neighborhood of the
European Union shows us
a terrible reality which is that this
dream is not a reality in all the
countries of Europe
with great sacrifice people in Ukraine
defend on a daily basis their freedom
and democracy their sovereignty and
their independence
against a brutal Russian army of
invasion and we support them in that
the ground the founding fathers and
mothers
assigned the growing Europe an important
task
which went far further than just
internal peace
for them Europe had a clear
responsibility
for Global
affairs
the well-being of Europe cannot be
separated from the well-being of the
rest of the world
to quote the Schumann declaration this
production coal and steel will be
offered to the world as a whole without
distinction or exception with the aim of
contributing to raising living standards
and promoting peaceful achievement
achievements with increased resources
Europe will be able to pursue the
achievement of one of its essential
tasks namely the development of the
African continent
back then the development of the African
continent stood in contrast to the
mainly europe-led Colonial exploitation
of our neighboring continent
even back then overcoming the
consequences of colonialism was an
essential feature of Europe's
partnership with the countries of Africa
Asian and Latin America
a partnership that left behind the
eurocentric vision of previous decades
and that not only calls for but
establishes
equal terms between us as partners and
establishing these Partnerships seems to
me more important than ever today
450 and perhaps following the next
enlargement perhaps 500 million citizens
live in the EU that's around five
percent of the global population
New Economic demographic and political
heavyweights are appearing in Asia
Africa and South America
a result of the distribution of Labor
between countries and continents which
have raised a billion people out of
poverty
and they quite rightly won't be
satisfied with a buy or tried Polo World
Order
and therefore I firmly believe that the
world of the 21st century will be
multi-polar it has been for a long time
already
but what does that mean for us in Europe
to quote the French author Paul Valerie
will Europe be what it actually is a
small Promontory a headland of the Asian
continent
and we can't find the answer to that
question by Looking Back
those who are nostalgic
for European great power status
fantasies
which remain among some people they're
stuck in the past as are those who warn
constantly of Europe's decline they
can't
win the challenges of the future
they underestimate one thing Europe's
ability to change and to act and that's
something that we've shown again and
again in the crisis of recent years and
of the present let's just think about
how we together
in a supportive manner came through last
winter
I think the three lessons to emerge from
that are as follows firstly Europe's
future is in our hands secondly the more
united we stand the easier it is to
ensure a good future and thirdly not
less rather more openness and more
cooperation at the order
are the watchwords of our time we need
to ensure Europe an appropriate place in
the World of Tomorrow
a place that is not greater or lesser
than that of other countries and regions
but on an equal footing with others side
by side
and in order to do that the European
Union needs to change we need a
geopolitical EU an enlarged and reformed
EU
and last but not least an EU that is
open to the Future
I see the European Parliament as a
driving force for all of those and also
an ally
let's look at the creation of a
geopolitical Europe for example
here 50 years ago
Willie Brandt talked about this as an
existential need
he wrote a United Europe isn't only a
question of the quality of our existence
it's a question of survival between
Giants
in a world divided between old and new
nationalisms
the European Parliament has always acted
in accordance with this Maxim and I'm
very grateful to you for that
you act along those lines when you
uphold the Primacy of the law
and when you recall that Europe can only
be listened to when it speaks with one
voice
Russia's beautiful brutal aggression war
of aggression against Ukraine has shown
us all how essential this is and as a
logical consequence
the European Union has rarely been more
united than in standing up to this
violation of European and International
the international order
so let's base a geopolitical Europe on
this experience
I made some proposals as to how that
should happen at the Charles University
in Prague Last Summer
we need
closer links between our efforts at
defense and the establishment of an
integrated European Defense economy
the European peace facility joint
procurement of ammunition for Ukraine
closer cooperation between our countries
on air defense our strategic compass and
close cooperation between NATO and the
EU all these are approaches that we want
to deepen and speed up
we now have to look to the
Reconstruction of Ukraine as well that
will require political and financial
Capital over the long term
but there is a major opportunity there
not only for Ukraine but for Europe as a
whole because a prosperous Democratic
European Ukraine is the clearest
possible rejection there can be to
Putin's Imperial revisionist revisit
revisionist and illegal policy
on our continent
we also need to compete with other great
powers
the United States remains Europe's most
important Ally
when we invest more in our security and
defense civilian resilience
technological sovereignty reliable
Supply chains
in our independence when it comes to
critical raw materials well those
Investments make us better allies for
our transatlantic friends
our relationship with China
can be described as competitor systemic
Partners competitor and systemic rival
and rivality and competitiveness on the
side of China have certainly increased
the EU has seen this and is reacting
I agree with Ursula V on the line when
she says no decoupling but a smart
de-risking is the way to go the
countries of the global South are new
partners
and we need to take their concerns and
interests seriously and that's why it's
so important that Europe works
supportively and decisively for food
security and to fight poverty
we also need to keep the promises that
we made at International climate and
environment conferences
that also belongs to a geopolitical
Europe
we need to rapidly conclude new
free trade agreements with mercosur
Mexico India Indonesia Australia Kenya
and also in the future with many other
countries
[Applause]
Fair agreements
that support our partners economic
developments rather than hindering it
they need to be fair and that means for
example that the initial processing of
raw materials needs to take place
in situ rather than in China or
elsewhere
if we anchor these thoughts in our trade
relations then we can make a major
contribution to diversifying our supply
chains
Europe must turn to the rest of the
world
if we continue to negotiate fruitlessly
for years
on new free trade agreements then in the
future will be others who dictate the
rules with lower environmental and
social standards
a key decision over the shape of a
geopolitical Europe
was taken last year and the European
Parliament was a driving force there as
well
we have decided to go for a larger
Europe
we have said to the citizens of the West
Balkan States the Ukraine Moldova and
potentially also Georgia you belong to
us
[Applause]
we want you to become part of the
European Union
and this isn't just about altruism
this is about our credibility and good
economic sense
and it's also about securing peace in
Europe
subsequent to the watershed moment that
was Russia's attack on Ukraine
a geopolitical Europe must keep its
promises
to its neighbors
and honest enlargement policy
sticks to its promises first and
foremost those made to the states of the
West Balkans to whom we've been
promising accession for 20 years
obviously the normalization process
between Serbia and Kosovo and reforms in
accession countries must be continued
obviously more rapid progress towards
accession must follow North macedonia's
courage as well
[Applause]
these steps forward need
to be appreciated and honored on our
side because otherwise the enlargement
enlargement policy users
its ability to act as an incentive and
the EU loses influence and attraction
honesty means an enlarged EU needs to be
a reformed EU
obviously enlargement shouldn't be the
only reason for reforms but it should be
an arrival point
and I expressly welcome the fact that
the European Parliament is working on
proposals for institutional reforms even
on proposals that don't spare the
parliament itself
and I will
continue to call on the council to
discuss these ideas now many things or
some things are obvious
more Council decisions through qualified
majorities for example in foreign policy
and on taxation
[Applause]
and I will continue to make
efforts at persuasion
and I'm very grateful for the wide
support I'm receiving
from the parliament
I would say to Skeptics it's not
unanimity
it's not 100 agreement on all decisions
that creates Democratic legitimacy quite
the opposite its efforts to get
majorities
negotiations for alliances that may Mark
us out as Democrats
the search for compromises
which are also in the interests of
minorities that reflects our
understanding of liberal democracy
I think we need to ensure that we stick
to democratic principles and the rule of
law within the EU as well and I know
that the vast majority of you are on my
side here as well
so why don't we use the current
discussion on reforming the EU to
strengthen the commission
and ensure that it can introduce
infringement proceedings when our basic
values are violated our basic values
such as Freedom democracy equality the
rule of law and guarantees of Human
Rights
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
there's something else which I just
mentioned which is important
as Europeans we need to open up to the
Future
without ifs or buts
that means dealing with problems that
have beset us for years
we need to
ensure that other countries can't split
us and play us off against one another
and here I'm thinking for example about
the way we deal with migration now
obviously we need a solution that's in
line with the European claim to
solidarity
but we can't wait until this solidarity
appears to us like the Holy Ghost
as Robert Schumann said 73 years ago
Europe is made through concrete
achievements through de facto solidarity
and I would therefore urgently call on
us to
conclude on the joint European Asylum
system reform
we've taken steps forward in Council
after long and difficult negotiations
and let's do that before the European
elections your agreement on negotiation
Ting position was an important part on
important parts of this reform last
month was an important step along this
path
so we need to conclude this work
we agree on the goal that we need to
better manage migration
without betraying our values
but
there is something that we could do
better than we have done so far
in many parts of Europe we urgently need
workers also from third countries
now if we link opportunities for legal
migration with the requirement for
Transit
countries and countries of origin to
take back those who have no right to
remain well then all sides will benefit
also we need to ensure the effective
protection of our external borders as we
agreed in the European council meeting
in February
that would increase the acceptance of
smart managed and controlled migration
to our countries and then we would take
the
Bedrock away from those who do Politics
on the basis of fear and resentment
opening up to the Future means that we
also need to deal with the most
important tasks that we face and here
I'm talking about our country's
economies and societies moves into a
climate neutral future
the first Industrial Revolution took
place started in Europe
and it should be our claim that the
Second Industrial Revolution also takes
place here to the benefit of everyone I
don't need to explain to you the
opportunity that we have here and it's
important for the citizens of our
countries to also feel that as part of
their daily lives
with cheaper electricity for example
made from renewable energies
so that we've got charging stations for
electric cars and lorries right across
Europe so that we have future oriented
jobs in the energy sector or in the
chips industry
because the entire world will need
the technology for climate neutrality we
need to shape this change in an
ambitious Manner and not leave anyone
behind that is the large project that we
need to look to as Europeans now
to quote Oscar Wilde
the future belongs to those who
recognize opportunities before they
become obvious
now this is not something for nostalgics
and it's certainly not something for
revisionists who dream of international
greatness or imperial power
ukrainians are paying with their lives
for this delusion on the part of their
powerful neighbor 2 200 kilometers
Northeast from here in Moscow Putin is
parading his soldiers tanks and
artillery
let's not be intimidated
let's stand firm in our support for
Ukraine
as long as is necessary
I don't think any of us wants to go back
to
a time when
the law of the jungle
reigned in Europe
when small countries had to bow to large
countries when Freedom was a privilege
of the few rather than a fundamental
right for everyone
our European Union United in its
diversity is the best insurance that we
have to ensure that this past does not
return
and that's why the comment the message
of the 9th of May is not what's coming
from Moscow today
the message
is ours and it is that the past will not
triumph over the future the future our
future is the European Union thank you
thank you very much
feeling down
thank you very much Chancellor Schultz
[Applause]
for that inspiring speech I give the
flow now to the representatives of the
particular group starting with the
president of the Epp group Manfred Weber
I would like to make an appeal for
everybody to stick to time please go
ahead
Madam president
commission representative
Chancellor Schultz welcome to the heart
of European democracy yesterday the 8th
of May
we remember the
Liberation from
Nazism and 9th of May we are happy about
the carriage of the fathers of European
Unity
just one day in the week perhaps a
chance of history but it's amazing that
between
there are only five years between these
two landmarks in European history which
um
showed courage to go against uh public
opinion at the time current odd now are
held out his hand for West Germany
um Stalin
chose European Unity uh
Germany chose NATO European Unity
against
um public opinion and other currents
today
we have the energy crisis and the rrf
all these things were managed but uh
ardna Cole and miteran they were
politicians who just didn't act in the
everyday they had to courage to act
they talked about the removing Unity uh
unanimous decisions in
foreign policy uh Emmanuel macron uh
organize an extra conference on the
future of Europe the re-election of Nag
macron didn't lead to a convention
Chancellor we need we don't need uh talk
about the fundamental rules we need the
courage to take Europe into the future
Europe needs leadership
and we in the EPP
we call for a convention to revision the
treaties to make Europe fit for the
decades to come
secondly
Europe is thankful for the clear
pro-european position of Germany all the
Democratic parties in Germany but we
need
the decision on operation of
combustion engines led to some
controversion controversy we need
big questions when it comes to China the
German Finance the Finance Minister
couldn't travel to China
they want to invest in the Hamburg port
the
we have a big
single marketer effect when it comes to
dealing with the Ukraine war
it seems that many people in Berlin
don't believe uh in the military
victory of Ukraine and now after a month
of debate the tanks are being delivered
many positions of your government come
to late and have too little ambition
Europe needs a clear clear signs from
Berlin and for the Christian democrats I
would like to say that we need to fight
uh climate climate crisis together we've
defined decided many things ETS Etc it's
not enough the sale of feesman is a
warning sign our companies don't believe
in the green deal it seems they don't
believe in the business case behind it
will we are we creating more jobs in
China or in Europe
we must see that we get a
competitiveness bias back on the agenda
food production is another
big topic we have inflation in food
prices we must export more to North
Africa we're not doing that and our
Farmers have been being made
um
they are being blamed and we don't need
that
when you came joined the sdp Willie
Brandt made a promise and I quote
more democracy we need to DARE more
democracy I'd like to ask you what does
this mean for Europe what does it mean
here for in this parliament in 2023
for me in the Epp
the election of a candidate means a
program an idea so that people can
decide it goes for a election of a mayor
or a Chancellor or for the election of a
president of the European Commission
unfortunately the proposals of this
Parliament for the Spritz and candidate
process and for the transnational lists
which were decided here were
um
were not accepted by macron or Michael
or Sanchez or by you so in the spirit of
Willy gunt Brandt less back room talks
in the council and more debates in the
European Parliament
we need to do all this today and not
tomorrow
[Applause]
to the president of the snd group Ira
Garcia Perez
[Applause]
thank you president
welcome
Chancellor my dear friend Olaf Schultz
it is a pleasure to welcome you to the
European Parliament on the day on which
we commemorate the birth of our shed
project to safeguard peace and Liberty
on our continent Chancellor on the 23rd
of May next the German SPD party will
celebrate its 160th anniversary 160
years building a free Democratic modern
Europe ever striving for greater
equality between citizens your presence
in this chamber comes at a time when
Putin's war against Ukraine has reached
a critical juncture with the Ukrainian
Army's spring offensive pending we want
to see peace in Ukraine but not if it
leaves a people conquered we would like
to see a just peace rooted in respect
for international law and for as long as
the of all last we must continue to
support the Ukrainian people in all
areas political humanitarian military
economic financial support as well as in
their fight against impunity we are very
clear on that in this house we are also
in a period of high infration inflation
that is hurting people particularly the
most vulnerable we must be Resolute
respect the goals of the social pillar
transpose the minimum wage directive
adopt a directive on minimum living
income and the right to housing a basic
right Mr Schultz we are aware that the
war has had an impact on German industry
and households thanks to your leadership
Germany has taken tough decisions
necessary decisions on mata's key to the
future of our EU military support for
Ukraine gas ceilings and now we need to
lead the way on reform of the
electricity Market to ensure reasonable
prices ladies and gentlemen if we want
to move towards much desired strategic
autonomy move towards re-industrializing
the EU then we need in addition to
approving the chips act and reform of
the electricity markets we must
accelerate work on the proposal dealing
with critical raw materials we need to
address social climate and environmental
challenges we need to ensure
re-industrialization and to this end we
need to strengthen economic governance
we need clearer flexible more flexible
fiscal rules so that we can strike a
balance between budget stability and
economic growth
today on the 9th of May we celebrate
Europe day for the Social Democratic
family Europe represents a community of
values values that are today called into
question by the far right
and those
in the conservative right that have
become the opposition now in Europe
we've seen that in Germany too
I believe that what is important here is
to strengthen the alliances that led to
the creation of Europe those shared
values we cannot give way to those that
look to destroy our European project
you will have much more in common with a
Chancellor Schultz
then miss Maloney for example
Mr Schultz
we social Democrats are not de facto
Europeans we are Europeans by conviction
in the darkest times in recent history
our commitment has never wavered I
firmly believe that on the 9th of May
there is no better gift than a
commitment on the part of the German
government to continue breaking
Deadlocks and striking agreements in
times of Crisis making Headway on into
great and breaking taboos working to
advance and Champion our
system of values in other words Champion
democracy freedom and respect for human
rights thank you
next is the president of the renew
Europe group Stefan cesion
La Presidente
president Chancellor colleagues
I'd also like to welcome you to the
European Parliament Chancellor
particularly
given that Germany's European
commitment has been a constant feature
of recent decades I should say
Chancellor that your Coalition has given
a new momentum to this commitment during
recent months
and renew Europe is proud that some of
our proposals such as transnational
lists the end of
unanimity in foreign policy
which is something that we need
given the situation with China
our official policies of the German
government and these are policies that
came from the fdp
now this new determination to rethink
Europe and look to the future is
crucial and your Prague speak Chancellor
was welcome now we members of the
European Parliament expect member state
capitals to articulate this vision of a
historical turning point because
managing crises is not enough we need to
prevent
the next set of crises we need to look
ahead and build look at energy
Chancellor for example
we've made it through the winter we've
made efforts to diversify our supplies
and accelerate on Renewables we've
worked in that sense on the in the in
the European Parliament but next winter
is the real challenge
and
this will be a particular challenge
given our increased need for electricity
we need to produce more electricity and
it cannot be carbon based so what are
your proposals at the European level to
ensure that our continent is at the
Vanguard
of the energies of the future Germany
also has a responsibility for the
stability of electricity networks in the
context of European solidarity given
that it is the largest economy in the EU
on digitalization our continent managed
to impose our ethical standards and our
model and I'm confident that we will be
in the lead on defining new
international standards on AI as we did
for the internet Giants and e-commerce
but Europe shouldn't just be there to
curb technological breakthroughs it
should be driving them
and we should be the place where
investments in Ai and Quantum are made
nevertheless we know there's a lot still
to do when it comes to freeing up
Investments and training
the green transition and the digital
transition are two pillars of European
sovereignty
and they will be successful because of
what Europe and its member states do but
also because we will provide a framework
that is favorable predictable and
sustainable for our businesses so they
can invest fully let me conclude
Chancellor to recall our support
for
Ukraine in terms of funding training
equipment and also weapons and I welcome
the effort made by the European
commission and in particular
commissioner Breton
on this during recent weeks my group
will every day continue to push every
state
to make more of a contribution to
ensuring that Ukraine can win this war
Germany has made taken decisive choices
on this could you tell us the next steps
in what you intend to do to support
Ukraine
Europe
needs to respect the sacrifice made by
ukrainians
and we need to adapt our institutional
framework so that we can welcome more
European countries
this is crucial
it's an important part of our European
DNA Chancellor you finished with a quote
I'll do the same a great Social Democrat
a French one this time Jacques delore
he used to say that Europe is like a
bicycle if it stops moving forward it
will fall over
I hope that together we will manage to
keep it moving thank you out of the
co-presidents
of the green group Terri reinska
thank you for president thank you madam
president
commission representative colleagues
Chancellor
you are coming to Strasbourg at a good
time because after the last month
uh
uh there's quite a lot to do
the traffic light
traffic light combination talked about
uh renewal and progress you party uh you
you said that you were a climate
Chancellor somebody who would do it and
deliver to be honest this present
promise this
impressed many for in Europe uh finally
a chancellor who wants to do something
after years of us standing still
somebody with an agenda I have to be
honest Chancellor you picture of you as
a chancellor who delivers in recent
years that has been uh
blown apart
and the uh
the
um
demands made by many in this Coalition
of the role in
um
for Germany and Europe
because the things are just trundling on
without having a clear position and the
uh
and there are doubts about the role of
German government as a reliable partner
in Europe
and the ban on
the combustion engine was a key part of
the fit for 55 package was the
chancellor says he does nothing and then
he hides behind the Coalition parties
who who have wasted the the trust of
European Partners to give another
example
rightly Chancellor
you
talked about a turning point for Ukraine
but in many places in Brussels and
Strasbourg and in many capitals of the
European Union it seems that
when it comes to every specific step it
goes
terribly slow
um
and we need action and that's not the
way in which a German chancellor should
position himself
I could continue this list
colleagues but that's not we're here for
I'm here Chancellor because I'd like to
appeal to you I'd like to appeal to you
because I'd like to see you fighting for
Europe because we need a German
chancellor who thinks and acts Europe in
the European way I'd like to have a
China chancellor who would like to learn
from his the failures of his parties
when it comes to Russia and doesn't
repeat those mistakes with China when it
comes to
um
human rights and have a clear strategy
on China and makes and strengthens our
economic and Industrial base I'd like a
China chancellor who know who that this
this continent is only competitive if it
sticks together and makes uh progress in
the green transition
even if it costs money
um I know who your finance minister is I
would like to see a chancellor who
convinces Germans that the stability and
growth Pact
that
can make these um is limiting these
Investments which are important for the
future I'd like to see a chancellor who
says and if you said this yourself I
come from a
a
a a
country which hasn't shut itself off
rather that it is open to the world so
I'm against an asylum policy which wants
to build up a fortress Europe I don't
want to see a Chancellor like that 73
years ago Robert Shuman
talked about the history of this
candidate he when the terror of Nazi
Germany brought death and destruction
and there were no people in Europe
who had hadn't lost loved ones he talked
about a a future of peace and living
together I would like to see a
chancellor who has a similar long-term
vision
you want the right things
enlargement the ability to act
the end of unanimity in the European
Council you want a convention but don't
be vague and make progress together with
this Parliament we proposed a European
convention I'm sure
if you uh urge that in the council we
can get a majority and before
and call a European convention before
the European elections thank you so now
to the co-president
CR group
[Applause]
melon presence
Mr Chancellor ladies and gentlemen
can you please listen to your colleague
to understand the role of Germany one
needs to start with the basic question
what sort of political system is the
European Union
and I submit it is a combination of an
oligarchy and a tyranny of the majority
the parliament functions of functions of
course is the tyranny of the majority
and the commission is a typically
oligarchic Institution
and
unelected with limited Democratic
legitimacy and having an unquestionable
lustful power and as far as I could
understand you Mr Chancellor you want
this body to have even more power
but the pillars the pillars of European
oligarchy are the big guys among the
member states
and the biggest is of course Germany
the big guys do what they want never
bother to consult anyone and call it
leadership
and with the votic system in the council
securing the interest there is little
chance they could be out voted
of many sins that the German governments
have committed let me mention too the
migration crisis when German is
single-handedly opened the EU borders
and recently the energy and security
crisis which resulted from its having a
long and murky tradition political
romance with Russia
today the German politicians beat the
breasts and promised to be good boys in
the future
well the problem with the big guys is
they can promise anything
and repentance as easy for them as it is
inconsequential
when I hear that the best option would
be the gradual abolition of the veto and
the abolition of the veto in foreign
policy I simply cannot believe my ears
the Russian policy was the most
spectacular disaster of the eu's big
guys and those who are most responsible
for this want to have more power in
foreign policies the logic behind it
boggles the mind the more we screw up
the more power we want
the logic would be the reverse because
you screw up so much you should be kept
in check for as long as possible
Chancellor Schultz I do not have any
Illusions about Germany mending its ways
you are
too big you are too hubristic especially
lately I read your statement and I
heard something like this today also but
Germany taking responsibility for the U
for the EU just a matter of interest if
you could satisfy my intellectual
curiosity where can one read about
German responsibility for the EU in the
treaties
the only proper thing for the German
governments would be to take the back
benches
and as political hygiene requires let
others run the show
you fail you should withdraw unless miss
the chance for you and your colleagues
in the European oligarchy believe that
German leaders
are forever
I give the floor next to Mr Gunner back
on behalf of the ID group
thank you madam president
are the Germans mad that is what half
the world thinks and the answer is yes
Germany is
suffering from some sort of Savior
complex and needs
help itself it is
endangering Financial stability and
racking up record debt levels what about
its climate ideas The Wall Street
Journal comes the daftest policy in the
world
Germany can't save the climate alone it
only accounts for some of the world
globe carbon emissions it is just
forcing through
retrofitting changes to homes and higher
costs will be the end result
Germany wants to save migrants to
five six seven million people from the
Eastern Africa that's what has arrived
on our shores of the last 10 years
curves about 700 that million euro
Africa can replace the entire German
population every few months 85 million
do you want to save them all and what
about your Russia policy together with
Merkel you
ensure that Germany was reliant on
Russia it was cheap gas and then the
north stream pipeline was blown up no
real explanation for months there's been
more and more sanctions uh levied
against Russia costing us a pretty penny
Ukraine cannot win this war despite all
the assistance Germany and the EU
suffers from a savior complex but
they're not really helping anyone they
are just harming themselves
psychoanalysis Mr Adler said that a
savior complex comes from an inferiority
complex the saviors tried to dodge their
own problems by focusing on those that
are suffering even worse Fates you don't
really care whether your help is of
benefit or not because you can't then
put your inferiority complex into
context here so Germany needs
psychological help to come overcome this
inferiority complex and to resolve its
savior complex unfortunately your
government is not going to pay the price
it'll be our citizens president of the
levs group Martin sure the one
foreign
thank you very much president Chancellor
people long for answers because of the
growing cases of social instability
unfortunately this is not something that
you focused on in your speech we see
exploding food prices rising rents every
fourth child in the European Union is
growing up in poverty and
45 million people have no idea how
they're going to pay their energy bills
and then on the other side you have an
increase of wealth uh simply
unimaginable levels and because of the
pandemic we are seeing the number of
billionaires explode we are seeing
I
huge profits being made out of war the
arms producers of the majority of our
populations however are not being
positively affected by your policies you
could have talked today about the
obscene excess profits that we're seeing
the ongoing growth of wealth of the
super rich you could have talked about
the growth or rather the fight against
poverty in the European Union
or you could have talked about a climate
policy unlike uh your foreign minister
which
doesn't allow the ongoing pollution of
the environment and the increasing
insecurity of those who have less
you
Terry I would also remind you you're
part of the government in Germany and
putting yourself forward is an
opposition simply isn't going to play
in 2022
the
Industries I'm talking about have made
record profits and Wonderland and others
have no better idea than simply throwing
more money at the arms industry I'm sure
that your predecessors the ones you've
mentioned Willie Brandt would have not
taken this mistaken path they would have
or Billy Brandt would have decisively
rejected it they would have promoted
peace and disarmament and this
commitment to a strategic approach to
the European Union is something I would
expect from Germany and you your Finance
Minister
um has
put almost a break on investment with
the development of the
or rather the rejection of a reform to
the U.N the the EU debt structure
so
we are seeing what I would Define as
National egotism and it's not
sovereignty we should focus on its
solidarity we need a solidarity base
pact for investment and the environment
and your government is failing uh it's
failing
in the area of migration as well you're
making this as a scapegoat for your
failures your interior minister is uh
coming up with no decent proposals and
the attitude for example to to the
status of children in the area of Asylum
and migration is something which is
extremely concerning I think we can
declare that you are politically
bankrupt Mr Schultz but I would say to
you that Europe is the future it's not a
future which is built upon the banks of
the poorest the weakest and the
vulnerable Europe needs to
look at the what is happening with the
super rich and we need to enter an age
of social justice thank you for one
minute
[Applause]
for president
Chancellor colleagues
precisely you Mr Schultz Chancellor of a
country which once enjoyed respect is
presiding over a country in a set of
Decline and turns up here making an
attempt at a Visionary statement this is
nothing short of laughable
Germany is under leadership which is
effectively in a vacuum in the wake of
de-entralization it is simply a laughing
stock amongst many of its neighbors it
is a country which has woeful
infrastructure high levels of
criminality and is in the middle of an
education crisis it has huge problems
with provision of pharmaceuticals
child care and is languishing in an Ever
greater
social welfare crisis and here you are
propagating your vision for the future
here in this house Helmut Schmidt had a
vision for the future but to yours
frankly would do better to
be the subject of a medical prescription
thank you
I'm shocked
Chancellor how
representatives of political groups talk
about you
[Music]
um
we've seen a member Reinke
talk about the disappointment of our
neighbors the
geopolitics of our German Chancellor is
throwing up a difficulties but I ask you
what policies are you talking about last
year you improved delivery of thanks to
uh Ukraine and the
German greens then come asking for
explanations you said in February that
it's necessary to have an effective
control of European borders at almost
all of the traffic like parties voted
against it the SBD and greens
voted for sanctions and then
your minister spoke against it it's
clear to everybody in Europe and
everybody who's here that in your
government in the traffic like Coalition
and in your particular case there is no
ambition for Europe rather there's chaos
we need ambition in Europe
and that's why many people
who are in Europe today are looking at
Germany and saying that maybe the
previous Johnson didn't always deliver
but now the government just isn't
delivering and there was a chance here
today but you didn't deliver with your
speech thank you
for president in
Madam president members of the
commission Chancellor colleagues
let me try to change the tone welcome to
the European Parliament Chancellor on
behalf of the SPD delegation of the
associates and Democrats
Mr Weber
ours is a chancellor who does very
clearly have a vision for Europe yet he
has simply not had an opportunity to
come and talk to us about his the
differences between his policies and
those of Madame Merkel and yet they are
great as we know these speech given in
Born showed us very clearly what
inaction and silence
on the European
continent could mean
but here
Chancellor Schultz is here for a
discussion with us and has already
flagged up a number of extremely
important points for example foreign
policy unanimity in the council but I'd
like to stop for a moment to talk about
tax many things are important in this
context not least energy energy costs
for these citizens and energy investment
for the citizens in the context of the
climate crisis
Russia's brutal attack on Ukraine
China's aggression against Taiwan the
effects of climate change there are many
factors which mean that we're in a
politically turbulent time so it's high
time that Europe reviews its position so
that future Generations can live in
peace and prosperity
European sovereignty and resilience
cannot be empty words we need to breathe
life into them innovative ideas and
implementation we need to
pursue the acts we have for example on
raw materials in order to ensure the
competitiveness of our continent but the
way towards more European sovereignty is
not a Sprint
let's not stop halfway around the track
we need to breathe life into European
renovation more trades and more
agreements with Democratic Partners no
backward-looking protectionism these are
key words and we welcome them we need to
bolster our prosperity on rather free
the middle-sized European Enterprises
from uh red tape more regulation more
prohibitions we need to remain
technologically open
this is the way that we can pursue a
climate neutral Europe we need research
and development for example in the area
of the fusion for CO2 free energy in
Europe but we need technological
leadership and we need to be first
in some areas again so we need a strong
responsible Germany in order to
facilitate this which is courageous in
the area of shared interests it like for
example the stability and growth pact
review let's take the challenges and see
them as an opportunity let's not duck
this let's make Europe a fit for the
future through cooperation
and motivation for the needs of our
people because these are our obligations
this is what we're committed to not
political parties already minutes
on
today is Europe day federal Chancellor
and we
stand up here in this hemicircle to
congratulate Europe and to wish you the
best for the future
many were driven out of your country and
out of the European Union and in the
past we have a lot to do to make our
European Union more coherent and fit for
the future especially in terms of
fundamental rights we need to speak up
loudly and clearly and we need for
example to make sure that European
projects are properly developed in line
with the European treaties rules and
regulations we need to be aware of what
is at stake for the European Union and
for its future
we need to stand up for freedom of the
press for example and we need to
sanction any violations thereof
absolutely clearly we need to support
aspirations to democratic Independence
and self-fulfillment these are all
valuable principles of the European
Union which are part of our principles
and part of our
roadmap for the future we want to
support other countries who aspire to
democratic and European values and we
want to stand firm against those who
come to them thank you for one minute
thank you very much events such as the
pandemic
cost of living crisis
unregulated migration all of these have
prompted us to revisit the role of the
EU and Germany
it's
clear that
citizens look to their National
governments in times of crisis
so Rev
be looking at further transfer of
authorities from the national to the
European level should be considered
carefully and we should not be ashamed
of protecting
um
the model of Europe as we consider this
your attitude towards a qualified
majority in the area of security and
foreign policy is something that needs
reconsidering these questions are so
important they should not be left to do
others I note an increasing anti-german
mood in this room and throughout Europe
as well I think a realistic future for
Germany as being a strong member of
Europe which is a union of
member states with equal rights pursuing
prosperity and peace for their citizen
sorry Harold williamskey for one minute
thank you sir many seconds
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen about a year before
the European elections is a very good
time to be drawing up a balance sheet of
what we've been doing in recent times
well frankly we've done everything wrong
everything we could have done we've done
wrongly and here we are with all kinds
of crazy policies being mooted to us
people who are suffering from
unemployment look at the crazy
vaccination policy that we had and look
at the ill-defined priorities of the
European institutions which are not
going to deliver the future that we need
we've been experiencing round after
round of sanctions imposed in the
context of the Ukraine war but have they
actually done any good no because
evasion of sanctions simply means that
Traders rely on India or on China or by
illicitly indirectly from America and
ultimately the European Union taxpayers
continue to pay the price this is
getting us nowhere it was ill-conceived
from the outset completely
mis-designed and this is what we've got
to correct before the European elections
so that finally people realize that they
can put people in this house who will
deliver a future for Europe rather than
this constantly ill-conceived
Fabrications thank you
country
thank you president metola president
Chancellor Schultz the five-star
movement has a very clear idea about the
future of Europe Greener more cohesive
and one without War
now your country is doing what it needs
to at home on these subjects um the
minimum wage and a trillion Euros for
Renewables but in bristles you have a
very different attitude and prevent
other member states from making the same
progress as you've made in Germany if we
think about reform of the stability pact
the position of your government which
has been expressed repeatedly by your
finance minister is a return to the past
which takes us back to the dark years of
austerity when GDP percentages mattered
more than people's lives without new
resources member states will not be able
to respect the European objectives set
in the green New Deal and for the
sustainable transition
green Investments therefore will be
excluded from a new calc a new
calculation of the new pact so finally a
reflection here in the um Parliament we
all talk about the future of Europe but
there can't be a future if there's no
peace today we need diplomatic action at
European level to put an end to the war
in Ukraine peace is built through
dialogue not arms
um which should not be for paid for with
European money next is secret murasan
for one and a half minutes
thank you madam president welcome to my
location
thank you welcome to the European
Parliament where there is a broad
pro-european majority looking for the
solutions for European citizens in order
to find these Solutions we really need
to carry out a successful diagnosis on
the 24th of February with the day of the
Russian invasion of Ukraine left us
looking at many changes not just in
Ukraine but in our European way of
living which has been attacked
European values of Freedom democracy
rule of law that's why it's so important
that as a European Union we've firstly
hold together work together in order to
support the ukrainians
if we've done that before and The
Invasion we might have been able to
prevent this attack but we weren't
active enough
and that is why it's necessary to be
Swift and strong in responding Ukraine's
secondly Russia had planned this attack
it wasn't provoked by Ukraine despite
the claims of Russia so we need to be
very active in fighting Russian
propaganda
thirdly we need to question
our understanding of the world the
approach of not provoking Russia
was incorrect not offering
NATO membership to Ukraine was incorrect
we shouldn't fear Russia
shouldn't be provoking Russia we need to
ensure that Ukraine is strong because a
strong Ukraine is the quickest path to a
peaceful Europe and in closing given we
want a rule-based union there are two
requests two percent of GDP for defense
as we agreed in every NATO member
country and second active
support for the
candidate countries it's absolutely
essential for European citizens and
Europe thank you for one minute
Schultz
thank you president Chancellor Schultz
welcome to the European Parliament on
today Europe day
you have had a decisive role in recent
times in the path of Europe particularly
um during the response to covert
this wasn't done uh only to uh thanks to
Epp but other parties as well now the
street we're following now is uh more
Europe
um not just broadening but also
deepening Europe
it's thanks to a comment rules that
we've been able to move beyond the
covert crisis we need to be
self-sufficient in various areas but we
can only do that if we have more Europe
we need to have permanent capacity for
investment in Europe that's what we need
if we really want to see more Europe for
one and a half minutes
Chancellor
yes
shaping Europe for the future but you
are to Great extent measured by your
action at home and I would say too
little too late is the conclusion yes
you were correct in identifying the
Paradigm Shift of our times a year ago
and yet Germany is not any better able
to defend itself than it was then
arguably less able so able to do energy
Supply well you have perhaps managed to
reduce your destructive dependence on
Russian gas and yet you have not
actually unleashed the wave of
Renewables you talk about yet you've
gone on to ban the generation of energy
from sustainable wood smes have always
been the backbone of our industry and
indeed delivered a great deal of our
growth but instead of openness to
technology to Innovation your government
comes to Brussels and simply contributes
to creating ever more bureaucratic
monsters complicating Supply chains for
example where there's a myriad of
legislation I'm a milk producer myself
and I would observe that you've actually
missed the boat in terms of this
Paradigm Shift it's left us all behind
in terms of security and supply of
Supply we simply don't have any we don't
have security of food supply in Germany
or in Europe despite understanding how
important it is we therefore need to
have the policy which we articulate
implemented at long long lasts we don't
need more bureaucracy we don't need any
more bonds we need action and we need to
deliver who is going to be responsible
for producing the high quality food that
we need once we've managed to destroy
the farm sector thank you
Chancellor Schultz your visit here today
is a reminder of the damaging effect of
the German migration policy
your coalition government with Merkel
and your we can do it in policy
led to more than a million
migrants into Germany and Europe and
unfortunately this policy has been
continued under your leadership it's a
policy which is destroying European
coherence a culture
and is challenging the cooperation the
work that can make Europe strong a
cooperation between strong and
independent states
so as a neighboring country
to Europe we would ask that you stop
this damaging and hopeless approach to
migration which has damaged Germany and
unfortunately European migration policy
for one minute
thank you president commissioner
honorable Chancellor I just wrote main
points you mentioned when speaking about
geopolitical Europe it is integrated
European Defense it is new free trade
agreements a larger Europe
institutional changes management of
migration flows and on the last place
United in diversity our slogan I just
want to stay on this and to ask you how
do you understand diversity whether
diversity finished within the borders of
23 member states national is National
States
27 National States and 23 official
languages I think it is not the way
Europe has to go I want to cite a good
ammunition who told either Europe will
become Europe of cultures or Europe
filled out and cultures are much more
than 27 and 23 and much more languages
and politics of linguistic
is taking place in many countries
especially in my country Lately by
abolishing education in minority
language but don't thank you very much
giving possibility to learn native
language it is not the way Europe has to
go
I give the floor next to Mr Andre
halitski for one hour for one minute
thank you very much
dear president uh the chancellor ladies
and gentlemen
this violent attack on Ukraine was not
an accident that is the result of the
weakness and of bad European policies
including the German one so we should
draw lessons and we should learn from
that so that we are not weak anymore in
the future as Europe
now the list of accusations could be
long
now the first polish question would be
well Europe needs Ukraine needs weapons
and money because if Ukraine fights and
wins then it will protect Europe where a
leopard
tankers tanks you should deliver on your
promises
but I have not heard any German
politician today that would not make
this long list of accusations because
you are not decisive enough
and so I have one very simple request to
you Chancellor now the future of Europe
is in our hands we need to be decisive
please if you don't want to make them at
least don't be an obstacle for one
minute
thank you very much Chancellor
paradigm shift
defining our times is something which
we've got to translate into reality and
the Socialists and Democrats have got to
ensure that this transition is just this
is something which is both internal we
need to deliver social justice for the
member states each and every one of them
because we have responsibilities to them
but equally we have Global
responsibilities climate change is a
grim reality we have responsibilities to
the outside world as well and I'm very
grateful to those who have spoken
including the chancellor about the need
to
work with Partners in Africa and Latin
America we want a global trust just
transition that's what we need to create
that's what we need to implement and
deliver and I'm very grateful that my
country is instrumental in doing this
thank you
[Applause]
this that console I would
Mr Chancellor half a century ago your
party decided to take a great step by
adopting its host politic as a Hungarian
I clearly remember the results achieved
by Germany in Central and Eastern Europe
times have changed however and the one
successful policy led to a point where
Germany became vulnerable to Putin's
Russia
in fact
it led to situations where you were
fraternizing with such politicians as
Victor Orban and his luck is
who had been undermining European values
and openly insulting your nation here in
this house too I don't think this was
worth it just like it's time for zeit
and Vida a major change in the relations
with Russia it's time for it in terms of
Central Europe as well I understand the
German corporate interests are important
to you but modern history teaches us
that freedom democracy and solidarity
among European nations are at least as
important let's stand up together
against Putin and his European disciples
let's work together to help center
Europe help catch up that's what I'm
asking you one minute
foreign
has to take his responsibility but
behind your words the Coalition is
putting Europe in uh danger you want uh
austerity uh everywhere you have huge um
support for the German economy and
um never mind for all the countries uh
that are left behind
um you talk about solidarity but we're
in the middle of an energy crisis and
you're closing your last nuclear
implants
here everything is being done to put an
end to this uh to call but um uh here
but um you're polluting with coal from
Germany
um you've said uh Chancellor that nobody
wants to go back to the time when it was
the strongest who ruled in Europe but
that seems to be only words
what's up
punters counselor it's a high time to
revisit these issues it is finally Gabby
Bishop for one minute
thank you president
Chancellor as the last speaker one has
the privilege of giving an overview of
the discussion today on Europe day
if you want to perhaps get a clear
picture of what we have heard there's
not much in the area of Reform and
review we work under pressure and we
need proposals for a change to the
treaties and we look for the two
bringing
proposals to the council many people
have mentioned Schumann today Europe
is created through Acts through specific
acts we are dependent upon initiatives
from France from Germany and on the
basis of those initiatives we can act
not just on and not just talk about the
reform of Europe thank you very much
back to Chancellor Schultz to respond to
the questions the comments and the very
interesting exchange we have had
Chancellor the floor is yours
they get
president ladies and gentlemen
I very much appreciate having this
debate and I appreciate all the
contributions I turned first of all to
you irate
and say that technology maybe wasn't on
our site but my attempts to learn
Spanish certainly enabled me to
understand enough of your excellent
speech to appreciate it very much and I
paid tribute to you for that
we Face many many challenges as we all
know we have to modernize we have to
take the European Union forward this is
our task for the future we need a
geopolitical union and I've outlined the
principles which will guide us to this
destination
a number of points have been raised this
morning which I'd like to make a few
remarks yes we
do need to consider are we for
enlargement have we decided to enlarge
the European Union if we have then we
need to make the necessary internal
reform so that Europe can continue to
function and this is why this is the
reason why I have said what I have in
terms of the need for reform we can only
enlarge if we move on from the unanimity
rules and we have quality qualified
majority voting on the central issues we
won't be able to do without changes to
the treaty in due course but we do need
to agree that it's not a domination of
minorities by majorities it is simply a
question of how we are able to act how
we are able to deliver the compromises
which we desperately need in order to
develop a successful democracy and this
is why I say what I am saying here this
morning in terms of tax and foreign
policy we need majority decision making
to make us able to act
enough
and of course there are a large number
of other questions which we're going to
have to discuss in the context of
enlargement and otherwise because there
are a number of
prospective members in the waiting in
the wings but there are many countries
in the European Union which when we
extend our solidarity more widely to
countries as yet with the EU will feel
the effects thereof and therefore we
need to look at the specific sets which
we wanted to take looking towards the
future and we need to be realistic we
need to have the courage of our
convictions and see what we need to do
and do it it is very very unfortunate
that 20 years ago we gave some prospects
to the Western Balkan countries of
accession to the European Union and we
have effectively taken no steps forward
at all this puts our credibility our
very credibility as the European Union
at stake and calls it into question many
political families have participated in
today's debate and have contributed
indeed to the debate over the years and
to taking forward the developments
towards greater enlargement many
countries are going to need major
constitutional changes and this is what
I hope we will be able to see in the
near future in the context of North
Macedonia I hope the Epp will support us
in our endeavors to support the
necessary constitutional changes we are
firmly convinced that we've got to
support enlargement and accession
processes in the right way in each
country and be open and supportive to
the citizens in all these countries to
bring them into the fold
but we need to do this in an orderly way
in a structured process and the North
and the South will only come together if
we agree that we are united in our
diversity but that our diversity can in
turn become our strength and I should
like to reiterate what I said during my
speech and it is this as we look towards
a future a world which will have an
additional 2 billion citizens and we
will still be half a billion here in
this continent if we don't act together
if we don't stand together we will
become irrelevant and insignificance we
will have no say on the future of the
world and therefore we need to move away
from the dominance which we shaped in
past centuries and we need to work to
become a good and fair and committed
partner based on unity and
commitment to the global community
many of you have spoken about the
appalling atrocities and the word of
aggression perpetrated by Russia this is
indeed a threat to peace and Security in
Europe and indeed to the entire world
through the Russian attack as we have
seen
we have called into question our
understanding of security our policy of
detailed pursued by the librant and
helmet Schmidt down decades we've seen
that there are those who don't believe
in borders who think that the osce
borders and the other political process
which is have delivered European borders
can simply be torn up
Russia has on a number of occasions
agreed in the context of these processes
on the borders but has now reverted to
an imperialistic Vision the that might
is right and that you can simply invade
the territory of a neighboring country
should you be so minded we will never
stand by and watch this we will never
allow this
and this is why it is so important that
we continue to support Ukraine
throughout
right as long as it is necessary and
that Ukraine be able to rely confidently
on our support and I've listened
carefully to all the contributions many
many of them in German throughout this
debate from a number of different
corners of the chamber
and from this I have cleaned a number of
conclusions
it is very important that we approach
these issues in the right way Germany is
the biggest Financial supporter of
Ukraine we are committed to continuing
on this path because we wish to continue
to support Ukraine in its battle to
achieve independence again and in its
battle for freedom
and Germany
is also in the Vanguard in terms of
supplying weapons there are those
amongst you who have I think forgotten
exactly what the reality is Germany has
supplied a large number of weapons and
will continue to do so and we have been
decisive in the context of discussions
with colleagues and others in deciding
to send battle tanks
for example
many people who were active in the
debate some time back have simply
disappeared from the field but now we
have done this and this is with the
support of the citizens at home and in
conjunction with carefully crafted
policy which we shaped in conjunction
with our colleagues so that we have
shared responsibility for a responsible
effective policy which serves the
interests of Ukraine and the people of
Ukraine that is what Germany stands for
that's what Germany is committed to
allow me just to pick up on a number of
points in energy policy I don't want to
leave any doubt about the position that
Germany espouses in the area of energy
security and energy policy not least in
terms of as pursued by my government
we are it is argued notionally
responsible for some two percent of
global emissions what are we doing to
counter this and what are we doing to
deal with climate change and reduce
emissions while our economic Innovation
our industrial Innovation our Engineers
our entrepreneurs our innovators and our
technology are making a great
contribution to enabling
Humanity to tackle climate change this
is something which we need to say loudly
and clearly the citizens of South
America of Asia their citizens in Africa
are able to Aspire to living standards
which we have in Europe and we need to
ensure that they can attain this because
it will only work for us if it works for
them and therefore we need to be able to
have universally available Technology
based on the industrial processes which
we are developing and delivering that
are globally available and that is
exactly what Germany is working to
provide we have committed ourselves that
by 2045 we will have a CO2 neutral
economy and this means extensive
electrification it means more
electricity production as has been said
on a number of occasions it also means
hydrogen rather than cold gas and oil
but between now and 2045 is
not even 25 years we have therefore got
to invest and Germany is a country which
has is an industrial Powerhouse
if 600 terawatt hours of energy is
consumed then we've really got to
recognize that by the end of the decade
it's going to be at least one third more
than that and by the 2030s we're going
to have to produce even more
considerably more and order of magnitude
more and this will have to come from
wind power on sea on land biomass
and other sources and we're going to
have to have 24 7 available energy which
means we've also got to work on
batteries and on storage and we've got
to work on enabling industry to function
with hydrogen and there are many many
other challenges but we can only address
these challenges if we have the courage
of our convictions if we are honest
about the magnitude of the challenges
and if we all work together and that
means the commission the parliament the
governments and that means that we have
got to
implement the goals that we've set
ourselves in all these pieces of
legislation and regulations we have got
to up our gain here the technology is
there we need the money we need the
investment we need to accelerate so that
we're investing at the pace that the
challenge requires so that we are up to
the challenges and this means for us
half a dozen solar or wind
power plants a day it means thousands
and thousands of pipes so that we can
transport energy it means
interconnectors it means offshore wind
power plants many many more than today
therefore the commission the Parliament
and the national governments need to
have the courage of their convictions
they need to understand yes legislation
is necessary to deliver the change that
we need
and we can't succeed in everything
overnight but we need to mobilize we
need to mobilize The Innovation that we
have the potential we have and then we
will generate economic
and economic development and investment
which will be an unparalleled
Improvement on what we have ever
experienced in the past
allow me to comment briefly
on our shared economic and finance
policy
I think that
we have a good tale to tell here
because we have put together the
recovery and resilience fund we have put
together Finance initiatives which I was
party to when I was finance minister of
Germany which have contributed very
effectively to
supporting the economy in the European
Union we were threatened by a global
pandemic which of course affected each
and every country of the European Union
we came together on a basis of
solidarity in a spirit of cooperation we
worked together before the funds were
even there and we put together
a framework on architecture for European
cooperation which was unprecedented and
this is why we knew that we can now rely
on this sort of cooperation going
forward and that the German government
will play its role to the hilt where
solidarity is required on each and every
occasion in the future
but I would also say that we stand for
stability and that includes fiscal
stability and that means that we need to
work in a rational way
together in order to find the right
solution and this is what we have in our
Coalition treaty in Germany and this is
The Logical consequence of long
discussions because we know we don't
want to precipitate austerity crisis in
any countries but it does not mean that
that anything goes in fiscal terms we
need stability this is critical and we
therefore need to limit debt
we need to ensure that we can't that we
don't just see disproportionate
unlimited escalations of debt because
that simply exacerbates crisis rather
than helping to resolve them and
therefore we need a balance and that is
what drives our position but with all
that in mind we will have hard
negotiations ahead certainly but we will
on the basis of solidarity come up with
a solution which is acceptable to and
applies well for all
there are those who have mentioned the
positive Deton that I myself have
mentioned helmet Schmidt and Willie
Brandt what I would like to say is this
if you look back at the longer Arc of
History then you realize that Willie
Brown helmet Schmidt's policy of detonte
was also at the same time at one in the
same time uh defense policy and it
enabled us to invest
up to some four percent in our defense
but now we in Germany are saying that
two percent of our economic G our GDP is
to be invested in order to achieve the
NATO goals then that is something which
lies absolutely
in the path in as a logical corollary of
villibrant and Helmut Schmidt's policies
it is a logical
step further down that line
let me say that we must not forget the
context in which we are working today
the Russian attack is a threat it is a
huge threat because it is something
which is grounded in the might is right
approach that might Trump's right and
law and we cannot simply pretend that
this is not the case this is a very
clear message that's been sent to us one
and all and therefore here in NATO we
have to the no stone unturned to make
quite clear that we are strong enough to
stand up against this we can and we will
we are an alliance of Peace where a
defensive Alliance we will stand up and
be counted and we will ensure that we
return to the consensus both in Europe
and globally it's not revisions but we
will not see
changings to borders being enforced by
violence and aggression
and therefore I am delighted to be able
to work in partnership with the European
Parliament I'm delighted to be able to
work towards the future on the basis of
Courage conviction yes of course there
are times when lengthy protracted
negotiations are necessary but results
can be achieved and in a world of
pluralism in a world of liberal
democracies where alliances across
member states are so important it is all
the more important that we come together
to find a compromise Way Forward that we
stand together
The Way That We Stand Together doesn't
simply mean that the Holy Ghost will
appear and that we will all
as a miracle agree
it means that we will use our
Inspirations that we will work together
that we will work with Partners both
within National parliaments and here to
achieve these high goals that we've set
ourselves democratic debate must lead to
a result which is good for all of us and
above all good for the future of the
European Union thank you very much
[Music]
thank you very much
thank you very much Chancellor Schultz
thank you dear colleagues we will move
now to the votes and allow the
chancellor to leave the room thank you